هل نلقي نظرة على ما هو على المحك
بالنسبة للسودان في النزاع حول سد النيل ،
فإن البلدان الثلاثة المعنية الآن في
طريق مسدود بشأن ما سيأتي لاحقًا.
اذهب للحرب
حول هذا ، استمع ، استمع ، فإن
القضايا المتعلقة بالمرأة
أو الامتنان في جوهرها
السد خطيرة للغاية وأعتقد أنه عندما
أدلى الرئيس السيسي بهذا البيان ، فإنه
يود منا أن نعرب لبقية
العالم
عن جدية  هذه القضية مرتبطة بالوقت
وهي مرتبطة
بأمن سلامة
الملايين من شعبنا في كل من
السودان ومصر وأعتقد
أننا نود أن
يتفهم بقية العالم خطورة
الموقف وأن
مرتبطة بالرعاية
قابلة للحل ، يمكننا حلها بسهولة
في غضون أسابيع
، وأعتقد أيضًا أننا نود رؤية
هذه
النتيجة في حدود
القانون الدولي ،
لذا دعني أسألك عن ذلك  رئيس وزراء السودان
لعدة سنوات ،
كان السودان سعيدًا تمامًا
بالذهاب لإثيوبيا للمضي قدمًا في بناء هذا
السد ،
وقد دعم السودان نوعًا ما هذه الفكرة
القائلة بأن إثيوبيا
بحاجة إلى وسيلة لتوفير الكهرباء
لمزيد من مواطنيها الآن يبدو كما
لو كان هناك  هذا النوع من
التغيير المفاجئ في دعمك ما
أدى إلى ذلك ،
نعم ، يجلب السد الكثير من الفوائد إلى
البلدان الثلاثة في هذا الشأن ، ولكن
لكي تتحقق هذه الفوائد ،
يجب أن نتوصل إلى اتفاق
ملزم يسمح لنا بالتخطيط
لحياتنا  أن نكون قادرين على استخدام المياه التي
تأتي
من السد بطريقة تسمح
بالإنتاج الزراعي
مصدر الرزق وكل ذلك بدون هذه
الاتفاقية سنكون دائمًا تحت
رحمة إثيوبيا لمنحها اليوم
وإغلاقها غدًا ،
ولهذا السبب نحن  يطالبون باتفاقية ملزمة في
إطار
القانون الدولي واه
سؤال آخر أريد فقط أن أركز
قليلاً هل
أه إسرائيل السودان طبعت العلاقات مؤخرًا
مع أنا؟  إسرائيل شعر الفلسطينيون إلى حد ما
بالخيانة بسبب ذلك ،
ما رأيك في
الرد الفلسطيني على التطبيع في السودان
أه بالعلاقات مع
إسرائيل ،
أنت تعرف ثورة
السودان العظيمة التي جلبت الديكتاتورية
السودانية المفتوحة إلى بقية العالم
واتخذنا
سياسة خارجية.  أن
تحول السودان إلى
بلد يعيش في سلام مع نفسه مع جيرانه
وكل ذلك عندما
يتعلق الأمر بقضية التطبيع مع
التطبيع الإسرائيلي
ليس حدثًا ، إنه
عملية
بدأناها ولكن
القول الفصل في هذه العملية برمتها  سوف
يترك للشعب السوداني من خلال مؤسساتهم